Okay, glooty take the app down kind of take it down, it's your app. I'm just an antenna
That's not how apps work
You think we're stupid but we're not we know apps have something to do with servers the service on the mothership where's the mothership
It's coming take us to it. Yes, shake it more Morty that was working. Take us to the mothership
Okay, okay don't hit an ominous beeping app, you can't stay mad at a guy with this kind of talent dad you can
We're just finishing season 4 while we're starting season 5 and we've got
Hi everyone happy comic-con. We got our first trailer for Rick and Morty season 4 so we got to break it down
you
Probably recognize the voice from that so they announced a whole bunch of stuff and details for what's going on with the episodes
And what's gonna be happening with future seasons will do a new Rick and Morty merch giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your favorite Rick and Morty moment on the video
So just starting with the clip then I'll address what they said about future seasons. The clip is actually taiga
What TD of Thor Ragnarok and Marvel Fame playing an alien app developer named glooty?
we don't know what the title of this episode is and we don't know which episode it actually comes from so this might not be
From season 4 episode 1 because the last time they showed off a clip at Comic Con during 2017
It was actually from episode 6 with them completely freaking out in and out morty twenty-minute adventure
So this could actually be from later in the run, but they did confirm that there would be 10 episodes in season 4
but the clip seems very reminiscent of a needful things type of episode with the devil like be careful what you wish for because
Glooty here. Has this tattoo warning on his forehead. Do not develop my app
like you should not do this thing because something terrible will happen and maybe
Stupid jerry takes it as a challenge because it sounds like it's either his app or is his and Morty's app like morty is in
on the
stupidity - because morty clearly has no idea how apps work and how the app store works because he's just shaking him make it how
It works
That's not how apps work
But its launch day and it seems like it's a dating app that they've developed because you look at their whiteboard and it just has
All these apps that sound like ripoffs of tinder. Ooh, la love cupid, er and love finders
It seems like that's the name of the actual app because they have a circle saying best idea, but he just starts taunting
Jerry, and it seems like he's threatening him with alien invasion
Like who the mothership is coming?
But the twist is is that the ominous beeping is just an ominous beeping app. So it sounds like wherever this alien comes from
He doesn't have quite as much power to back up the threats that he's throwing
them but it kind of reminds me of that Simpsons episode where they gave Homer the
Opportunity to design a new car and it wound up being the worst car in the history of the world completely
Ruining his brothers company like Jerry has the opportunity with Morty to develop this cool new app
And it winds up being the worst thing ever with terrible consequences
Which is probably why they're trying to take it down so fast like oh my god
We have to take this down because something terrible is going to happen
The way Morty's getting super violent in this to remind you a little bit of how he was acting during Morty's mind blowers
He's slowly starting to act a little bit more like Rick
He's almost come full circle because he starts out being really timid. Then he gets more assertive
Then he starts to go against Rick by the beginning of season 3 and then sort of comes back around on him by the end
Like oh no
We need Rick and he searched to act more like him maybe without realizing it because the whole idea of season four
Is that the family power dynamic is returning to something more akin to what it was during season two where Rick seems like he's not
Dominating the family quite as much but then you have situations like this where Morty seems like he's starting to go full Rick
Like I said, though
There are 10 episodes in season 4 and in that comic-con clip Dan Harmon clearly says that they've already started working on season 5 episodes
So they did a big interview where they revealed a whole bunch more details about what's going on
They said that even though there's only 10 episodes during season 4
they said there's a way that they structured their deal is is that they can deliver as many
Episodes as they want at a time
So if they get ahead of schedule, there might be future seasons with more than 10 episodes per season
But the bare minimum is 10 episodes per season
So either it'll be 10 or it'll be more than 10 when we get to season 5 and because of some things that they change
Behind the scenes with the way they make the episodes as Dan Harmon implies during this comic-con clip
They now have the job security in the system to keep the trains running on time
So we won't have to wait more than a year to get season 5 they could wind up dropping it before November
wanderlust is here now! timestamped - Summer Dawn Gibson -Williamsburg VA 23185
2020 like we could get it during the summer, but I'm just assuming it's on a yearly schedule to be fairly predictable
So just assume November release dates from here on out
But for all of you wondering if they were planning on
Canceling Rick and Morty or ending it after their 70 episode renewal because that's a lot of episodes
They said that they don't plan on ending the show anytime soon
Justin roiland
said in this interview that he feels like the show could go for 20 more years just like the Simpsons because the characters don't
really age in real time like traditional drama characters
So they plan on making the show as long as they have new stories they want to tell so don't be surprised if they make
It to 150 or even 200
Episodes but that's like so far down the road that obviously they're not going to know about that till they finish this first 70 episode
block
You may have seen all the pictures Dan Harmon and the writers have been posting from the writers room what they changed behind the scenes
Is that they brought in a more administrative showrunner?
so the Dan Harmon could offload a lot of the
Non-creative work to this other person and this other person is sort of the traffic cop that keeps the trains running on time
When Dan Harmon goes on a big white tangent?
but the funny thing is is that Dan Harmon was joking on Harmon town about just completely
messing around in the writers room and is like well this other guy that they brought in to be showrunner can't fire me because I'm
the creator I'm in charge of everybody but the way he talks about their creative process just makes it sound like now he's spending all
Of his time thinking about stories and writing scripts and this other showrunner guy is just doing everything else that he doesn't want to do
They did say that you would absolutely have to re-watch season three before you start watching season four and confirmed that there would be serialized
Elements of the mythology continuing in season four mixed with the one-off episodes same way
They did it during season three
Which I feel like confirms is a continuation of the evil Morty storyline The Citadel of Rick's and based on some of the other
previews that they drop like the crock you bought picture where it seems like they go to Crocky BOTS home planet seems like The Vindicator
storyline is continuing to in some sense or at least they're
exploring some of this larger of indicators mythology because that episode sets up all this crazy backstory like they've been on all these
Adventures that we've never seen actually know Morty
We've actually done a couple other adventures without you because we didn't want to have Rick along we felt like he was a bad mix
For the group, they didn't say exactly which other stories are going to be coming back
They did reference bringing back a lot of characters from previous seasons, but this is that that's always on the table
They just try to find the right story to bring certain things back like mr. Poopy butthole popping up all the time
See you for season four in like a
really long time
I might even have a big white Santa Claus beard
The really big guest stars that they announced include Taika Waititi who's playing this glooty?
Alien app developer character during the season 4 trailer that you just saw sam neill of Jurassic Park Fame
They didn't say exactly
what he's doing or what he's playing or if it's going to be another Jurassic Park reference because they kind of already did that with
John Oliver's character
They also have Paul Giamatti playing a character and Kathleen Turner
but obviously they didn't say who's they're playing or what their characters are like
They did say that they're also still planning on doing a Kanye West episode, but it won't be till season 5
They actually talked quite a bit about that whole Kanye business from last year
So if you don't know what the Kanye business is about last year Kanye West tweeted out the most
Celebratory fan tweet that you could possibly do about Rick and Morty season three justin. Roiland naturally saw it
He makes a lot of music and funny parody songs for Rick and Morty episodes that they then released later
Kanye West's teasing that he wants to be a part of Rick and Morty so it's like why don't you just get together and figure
Out an episode to do together recently
They said that they did have very earnest talks with Kanye West about getting together to figure out an episode in a character for him
To play and something to do together during a Rick and Morty episode but because of what they've been doing working on getting season four
Out and because of Kanye West's schedule
They haven't been able to actually sit down to figure out what that episode is going to be
So the Kanye West episode won't be at least til season 5
But they do plan on doing it at some point
I would expect it to be a mix of him playing an actual character
But also singing a song or writing a new song for the episode just because that's such a very Rick and Morty thing to do
Get schwifty with Kanye West
Moon Man sequel any of the best songs of Rick and Morty that you could possibly think of so I'm just really excited to see
What ends up coming of that if they announce any other big things during their panel or they drop any more?
Animatics or teasers or anything like that. I'll totally do videos for it, but there'll be more Comic Con trailers dropping later today
I'm also working on a Witcher comic
Trailer that should post in a little while and then obviously all the big Marvel and DC stuff happening on Saturday
So as long as you have alerts enabled for my channel, you see all the videos when I post them
It's just a reminder that Rick and Morty season four is gonna premiere in November
But you do have an opportunity to see season four episode one before everyone else
you can click here to learn about that and you can click here for all my
Spider-man far from home post credits scene Easter eggs. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight